اهلا بكم اخصصوا حلقه هذا الاسبوع لساعه
يوم القيامه البعض منكم بالتاكيد يعرفها
والبعض سيتعرف عليها من خلال هذه الحلقه
هذه الساعه المصممه للتنبؤ بمدى قرب
البشريه من الاباده المروعه مع تصاعد
التهديدات النوويه استضيف للحديث عن ذلك
عضو مجلس العلوم والامن التابع لنشره
علماء الذره التي تتولى تحديث الساعه
السنويا فخامه
رئيس دوله منغوليا السابق من العربيه
احييكم دائما انا منتهى الرمحي وهذا البعد
الاخر
[موسيقى]
في يناير حدث مجلس العلوم والامن التابع
لنشره علماء الذره ساعه يوم القيامه
المصممه للتنبؤ بمدى قرب البشريه من
الاباده المروع ساعه القيامه هي ساعه
رمزيه انشاها عام
1945 علماء بعضهم شارك في برنامج صنع
القنبله نوويه ومنذ ذلك التاريخ يقوم
اعضاء المجلس سنويا بتعديل الوقت للتفكير
فيما اذا كانت احداث العام السابق قد دفعت
البشريه الى الاقتراب من الدمار او
الابتعاد عنه
المجلس الذي يضم احد عشر عالما من
الحائزين على جائزه نوبل ومقره مدينه
شيكاغو الامريكيه قام باول ضبط لساعه يوم
القيامه في سبع دقائق قبل منتصف الليل
لتحديد مدى قرب العالم من الاباده النوويه
في عام 49
حرك محرر النشره عقارب الساعه من سبعه الى
ثلاث دقائق قبل منتصف الليل بعد ان اختبر
الاتحاد السوفيتي اسلحته النوويه الاولى
في عام 53
تحركت الساعه الى ما قبل منتصف الليل
بدقيقتين فقط بعد ان فجرت الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي اول اسلحه
نوويه حراريه
وقبل عام ثبت المجلس عقارب الساعه عند 100
ثانيه فقط قبل ساعه الصفر وهي الثانيه
عشره منتصف الليل اخذت النشره في الاعتبار
التغييرات الجديده التي طرات على العالم
مثل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والتهديدات
البيولوجيه وانتشار الاسلحه النوويه وازمه
المناخ المستمره بالاضافه الى تهديدات
اخرى تدفعنا الى الاقتراب اكثر من اي وقت
مضى من الانقراض للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بفخامه الشاجين
البجدارز رئيس دوله منغوليا السابق عضو
مجلس العلوم والامن في نشره علماء الذره
معنا فخامه الرئيس وفي البدايه لو تشرح
لنا مفهوم ساعه القيامه
اوكي
هذه يوم القيامه كما ذكرتي بدات في عام
واجتمعت
العقول العبقريه لبدي هذه الساعه ومنذ ذلك
الوقت فساعه يوم القيامه وحتى اليوم
عده 25 مره
وتسعه عشر مره
الى الامام
ومرات اخرى الى الخلف والان عده ساعه الى
تسعين ثانيه قبل منتصف الليل
وعندما
[موسيقى]
الانسانيه واصحاب القرار بشكل خاص حول
الازمات النوويه
والازمات المرتبطه بالاسلحه النوويه ولكن
بعد ذلك في الحقيقه فان يوم القيامه
اخذت ابي نظر الاعتبار التهديدات الاخرى
الان
نقول ان هناك ثلاث تهديدات اساسيه مرتبطه
اولا الاسلحه النوويه والجائحه
والتهديد الاخر هو ازمه المناخ
والتهديد الرابع الناشئ ونسميه
التكنولوجيا الاحلاليه او التقنيات
التخريبيه وكل هذه جنبا الى جنب تجعل
عالمنا اكثر ضعفا كما ان الساعات يوم
القيامه ودون اذكر مساله هامه هي في
الحقيقه تحذر الانسانيه
من تلك
التهديدات التي سببها البشر ونسميها
تهديدات وجوديه وساعه يوم القيامه اخيرا
في عام 2020
اعدت الى 200 ثانيه وعشرين واحد وعشرين
قرروا ان لا يحركوها اما في عشرين 23
فالعلماء
وخبراء اخرون ممن درسوا المشاكل الامنيه
قرروا
باعتادها الى تسعين ثانيه قبل منتصف الليل
لمن لمن توجه نشرات اعدادها الى 90 ثانيه
قبل منتصف الليل او ثلاث دقائق او تسعين
او مئه ثانيه كما كانت في عام 2021
هل توجه الى الزعماء الى الرؤساء ام ان
المفهوم يتعلق فقط على المستوى المستوى
البشريه بشكل عام في العالم
بالانسانيه جمعاء ولكنها تركز بشكل اساسي
اللي نشري الوعي لاصحاب القرار واصحاب
القرار نقصد بذلك في كل دول العالم كل
دوله الان
تواجه الصعوبات المرتبطه بازمه المناخ
وكذلك صعوبات مرتبطه بالجائحه
واذا ما حصلت كارثه نوويه
فاثارها بالتاكيد ستكون عالميا
وحيا الساعه رمزيه
اليوم هو مثل بناء اليقظه
هذه التسعون ثانيه قريبه جدا من منتصف
الليل في عام 91 وفي نهايه الحرب البارده
فالنساها عدت الى 17 ثانيه فقط من منتصف
الليل
او سبعه عشر دقيقه اما فيما يخص
فكانت ابعد بكثير اما الان فهي قريبه جدا
من منتصف بعشره اضعافها فقط 90 ثانيه من
منتصف الليل
لو تعيد لي فقط التحديثات التي اعلنتموها
اليوم هل مساله 90 ثانيه قبل الثاني عشر
منتصف اليوم مساله نهائيه هل اقتربنا من
هذا اليوم وما هي الاسباب حقيقه وراء هذه
التحديثات اللي تم الاعلان عنها
الاسباب وراء هذه التحديثات هي التهديدات
الوجوديه
المرتبطه بالاسلحه النوويه
والكوارثه المناخيه
والجائحات
كما ان هنالك التقنيات التخريب يوم سما
بالاحلاليه فمثلا الذكاء الاصطناعي فهذا
يذكر الجميع
مدى قربنا من يوم القيامه او الهلاك وكل
اصحاب القرار عليهم ان يتذكروا دائما ذلك
وعندما يتاملون
هذا الوقت الضيق فسوف يتخذون القرارات
الجيده على سبيل المثال خلال الجائحه
عندما قدموا اللقاحات الجديده
وعندما
تظافر جهود العالم في الحقيقه تمكنا من
منع العديد من الوفيات والكثير من الاشياء
سلبيه
جنبا الى جنبي مع العلماء ومع الباحثين
نستطيع
ان نجعل قراراتنا اكثر ودقه
الرئيس
المره الاولى هذه التي تضيفون فيها
العوامل المناخيه للتهديدات والمره الاولى
التي نتحدث فيها عن التكنولوجيا والذكاء
الاصطناعي تم النظر الى انه ذكاء
الاصطناعي
بجله ايجابي هل هذا يعني انه خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي تهدد البشريه الان من اي نواحي
تحديدا وماذا عن البيئه
البيئه بالتاكيد مساله ملاحظه طارئه اما
فيما يخص الذكاء الاصطناعي فكلنا نعرف بان
هي مساله مقلقه للحكومات وكذلك للانسانيه
انا عضو في المجلس
وليس لدينا اي مصالحه وفقط ان نريد ان
تعيش الاجيال المستقبليه حياه جيده
وبذلك فنحن سعداء جدا
للمشاركه في هذا الحدث
ونحن نقول ان هناك فشل في القياده الدوليه
فعندما نفشل علينا
نذكرهم بفشلهم والان عليكم اتخاذ قرارات
افضل يعني هذا قد يكون مفهوم كثيرا
بالنسبه للاسلحه النوويه تطويرها بالنسبه
لعدم الاهتمام بالبيئه لكن فقط اريد ان
اركز قليلا على
نوعيه التهديد الذي نتوقعه من الذكاء
الاصطناعي هل هل ممكن ان تعطينا فكره
انا لست خبيرا في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وقرات الكثير عنه
وانا بالتاكيد اتبع الاجل العلميه فاذا ما
كان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يتجاوز القدره العقل البشري
فكيف نتعايش معه اذا ما كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي
حتى قدراتي وقوتي البشر تسليم مثل تهديدا
لهم وهذه مشكله كبيره اما من ذلك فعلينا
ان نركز بشكل اكبر على التهديدات النوويه
او التهديدات الوجوديه التي
زادت خطورتها مثلا الاسلحه النوويه والحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا اليوم
وتلك البيانات التي صدرت خلال الحرب
فكلنا نعرف ان الحربقه تتحول الى حرب
نوويه وكل هذه المسائل مرعبه جدا كما ان
هنالك الكوارث الطبيعيه فنحن نشهد
تبعات التغير المناخيه عبر الكوارث
الطبيعيه وحتى الجائحه التي ذكرتها قبل
قليل
كيف كيف تقيم لي التهديد النووي في هذه
اللحظه على المستوى العالمي
لا شك بان
التوسيعي على الترسانات النوويه لدى القوى
النوويه الكبرى وهذه القوه النوويه
عن
معاهده الصواريخ متوسطه المدى
وفي هذه البيئه السياسيه العالميه اليوم
بين القوى العظمى
يجب ان تكون هنالك معاهده بينهم ويبدو بان
المفاوضات بعيده جدا وكل ما نعرفه
هو ان
التهديد الخاص بالاسلحه النوويه او هذه
المعاهده سوف تنتد في عام 26
ولكننا سنحتاج الى المزيد من الوقت وعلينا
ان نبدا بالتفاوض الان وعلينا ان نعقد
الاجتماعات بين هذه القوى العظمى هو هذا
نداء جيد لتحقيق ذلك فخامه الرئيس ارجو ان
تبقى معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير نعود بعده
لمتابعه هذه الحلقه من البعد الاخر
اهلا بكم معنا من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
ومره اخرى بارحب بفخامه شاهين رئيس دوله
منغوليا السابق عضو مجلس الشيوخ واعود
اسالك مره اخرى عن
تقييمك كون ذكرنا في الجزء الاول من البعد
الاخر الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه تقييمك في
التركيز في الاونه الاخيره على مزيد من
تسليح اطراف الحرب كيف يمكن الحد من هذا
خاصه انه الحرب بدات فعلا تتخذ منحه وجودي
والحديث عن الجلوس الاطراف على طاوله
مفاوضات يبدو انه لا يوجد صدى عند الاطراف
اوكرانيا لديها كل الحاق في الوجود وهذه
الحرب شنها الجانب الروسي
وهذا اعتداء الصارخ ضد الدوله مستقله
بلا شك تسببت هذه اللي حابب مشاكل جمه
خاصه على النظام الدولي
اعتقد بان هذه الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي بشكلين
رسم اذا
ما خرج المعتدي الروسي من اوكرانيا
او خلف هذه الحرب الروسيه انا اعرف هو
الرئيس بوتين
وعبر هذا البرنامج او انه اطالب الرئيس
بوتين بوضع حد لهذه الحرب والتحرير كافه
المناطق الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
والسحب قواته من اوكرانيا فاذا ما فعل ذلك
فهذه الحرب ستنتهي فورا اما
اذا لم يحصل ذلك فعل الانسانيه جمع ان
تدعم اوكرانيا في حربها من اجل بلادها
وكذلك لحقهم في الوجود
سيصل الامر الى مسائله ومحاسبه كافه
الاشخاص المسؤولين عن هذه الحرب وهذه
الحرب بالتاكيد لا يجب ان تصل الى المستوى
النووي او تمضيه هذا الاتجاه ولا يجب ان
يكون هنالك تصعيد والكل في العالم
يريد ان
جرى حلا سلميا في اسرع وقته وانا من بين
هؤلاء ونحن نحاول الانخراط مع كافه
الاطراف ونحث الجميع
الابتعاد على العنف والبدء بالمفاوضات
والحديث في اسرع وقت صحيح انه لم تبدا حرب
نوويه او لم يعني يعلن عن حرب لاويه لكن
هناك مراقبون يتحدثون عن كون فعلا دخلنا
مرحله هذه الحرب بشكل متدرج بعد ان كثروا
الحديث عن اسلحه رو واوكرانيا التكتيكيه
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يكون هذا الخطر مشابه
لحرب نوويه
من وجهه نظري اعتقد بان كلا الجانبين وبلا
شكل الجانب الاوكراني فاروسيا لديها هذه
الامكانات او الاحتمال النووي وروسيا من
وجهه نظري ليس لديها اي نوال لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
لان هذا ما حصل هناك اي استخدام لاسلحه
نوويه
فسوف تحصل كوارث كبيره وسوف تدان روسيا
عالميا
وبسبب ذلك اعتقد بان روسيا
تجنبت حتى استخدام هذا الخطاب لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه ولكن
من اجل حل هذه المشكله
فكل حرب يمكن ان تنتهي محادثاتي السلام
وعلينا ان نفكر بهذه المحادثات لو تسمح
لنا بصفتك رئيس سابق لدوله تقع بين روسيا
والصين ومجاوره لهما كيف فينا نقيم المشهد
الدولي فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات بين الشرق
والغرب
كما تعرفون
المجاوره لبلاده الصيني هو
روسيا ومنغوليا هي الديمقراطيه الوحيده
بين البلدين منذ عام 1990
وكل دوله من ضمنها حتى دول الجوار
لمنغوليا يحترمون استقلالنا وسيادتنا
وخيار شعبنا
اعتقد باننا يجب ان نستفيد من التعاون
وليس من المواجهه
الدوله
الديمقراطيه ومسالمه ونطالب ونحث كافه
الاطراف على المزيد من التعاون وليس
المواجهه
عبر ذلك
فبامكاني ان نحدد العلاقات بين دول الشرق
والغرب
كيف يمكن تهدئه الوضع على المستوى الدولي
اذا ما نشرنا المزيد من الوعي
واذا ما اصغى القاده
[موسيقى]
الاشخاص الذين يرفعون اصواتهم
واذا ما اطلعنا على الادله العلميه
كل عوامل المؤثره على حياه البشر واذا ما
حاولنا ان نجعل عالمنا مكانا افضل
عبر اتخاذ القرارات الجيده اي تلك
العلاقات المرتبطه بحياه البشر
فبامكاننا ان نهدئ التوترات
وبلا شك وبهذا الخصوص
فان المنظمات ادوليه المتعدده يجب ان تلعب
ادوار
المتحده وحتى المنظمات الاخرى
يجب ان تقوم بعمل اكبر
لتهدئه تلك التوترات
بين الدول
نفهم بانه ساعه القيامه هذه كل ما اقتربت
من الثانيه عشره منتصف الليل وكانه يرتفع
خط الخطر الى اللون الاحمر هل حصل انه من
عام 45 من وقت انشاء هذه الساعه حتى الان
او من قبل ذلك ان تراجعنا عن بدلا من ان
نتقدم نحو منتصف الليل هل حصل انه تقدمنا
وتراجعنا الى الخلف
في الحقيقه عندما بدات عام 1947 بدات من
سبع دقائق
وكل ما نعرفه من تاريخنا فالانسانيه كانت
قريبه جدا من نقطه حرجه عندما حصلت ازمه
الصواريخ الكوبيه وحصر ذلك عام 1962
وبعد عام 63 تم اعداد ساعه يوم القيامه
ولكن عندما
حلت تلك الازمه ازمه الصواريخ الكوبيه عبر
السوق السلميه
واتخذت الانسان انفاثا عميقه وبالتالي فقد
اعيد ضبطها على سبع دقائق
وايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
والولايات المتحده عندما وقعوا معاهده
الاسلحه النوويه حول خطي الاسلحه النوويه
وكذلك منع وحظر التجارب النوويه
فالضبطت الساعه يوم القيامه الى 17 دقيقه
في عام 91 ومن ذلك الوقت وساعه يوم
القيامه لم تتراجع دائما اقتربت من منتصف
الليل
ولهذا اليوم اليوم بالتحديد وصلت الى
اقرب ما يمكن وهذا يعني باننا بحاجه الى
المزيد من التظافر والتعاون والتفاهم
والادله العلميه واضحه اعتقد
علميه ليست مرتبطه باي قوميه وليست محليه
بل هي عالميه
وعندما ضبطوا الساعات يوم القيامه الى 100
ثانيه في عام 2020
اعتقد بانها كانت دقيقه جدا فاذا ما
اطلعنا الى نزاعي في اوكرانيا
والجائحه
فاعتقدوا بان هذا التوقيت الدقيق جدا
وتقريبها عشر ثواني اليوم
ايضا
توقيت دقيقه خاصه اذا ما اصغينا الى
الخبراء او الذين قدموا الادله العلميه
فالامر منطقي جدا
الان الامر كله بيدي اصحاب القرار
العمل
ونشر الوعي وعليهم ان يفكروا بساعه يوم
القيامه من اجل ابعادها عن منتصف الليل
يعني
اود ان اقول
احنا مهما كانت المخاطر عاليه فهنالك
دائما الامل
ودائما هنالك الاشخاص الراغبين بالتعاون
وكذلك الدول ترغب بالتعاون
وهنالك التطورات التكنولوجيه عظيمه وهنالك
امكانات كبيره جدا لحل كل تلك المشاكل
المرتبطه بالتسليح وكذلك ازمه المناخ
والجائحات واعتقد دائما هنالك الامل
كما كان يقول الامر دائما يبدو مستحيلا
الى ان يتم وعلينا ان نسعى للعمل الجيد
والصالح واذا ما عملنا جاهدين واصرنا
فستكون مخرجات جيده شكرا جزيلا نحن الان
تسعين ثانيه قبل منتصف الليل في ساعه
القيامه شكرا جزيلا لك فخامه رئيس دوله
منغوليا السابق شاهين
عضو مجلس الشيوخ في نشره علماء الذره الف
شكر
والى هنا انتهت حلقه اليوم من البعد الاخر
يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما
يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا على العربيه
بودكاست الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]